the Joe Rogan experience like they could
do that with anything so who the [ __ ]
world's the Bruce Lee movie with Jason
Scott Lee man that was filled with a
bunch of [ __ ] he's made [ __ ] up he
had a famous fight where he learned Wing
Chun doesn't really work on Americans
yeah it was it was in a YMCA he was
fighting for the right to teach
foreigners kung fu because the elders
that lived in San Francisco or Seattle I
forget I think the San Francisco they
didn't want him to teach foreigners and
they said if you beat this if you beat
our guy up then we'll let you teach
foreigner so he had this fight it was in
the YMCA but in the actual movie it's in
a [ __ ] dungeon dude nor the Rings
it's like [ __ ] Riggs that's right
it's the craziest thing they didn't have
to go that far but I guess it was just a
YMCA did he win the fight yes but he
didn't in real life he had a he hurt his
back doing squats or doing deadlifts it
was really bad here it is so that's when
he wrote his first book is when he was
like in the attraction is that what they
call it when they your backs in some
kind of spinal or some kind of brace but
so but in the movie the dude kicked him
in the back and broke his back oh yeah
tricky yeah yeah and then he's there's a
famous appearance of his at the Long
Beach Convention Center back in the 60s
it was like a karate tournament and he
did some demonstrations he did there's a
video famous video of him doing the
one-inch punch it's in front of it's
like at the like an IBJJF tournament
he's doing a demonstration and in the
movie it was a real fight and he fights
the same dude from the dungeon at the
remap oh no you guys think why would
they do that I need to his life was
amazing in you know in reality are they
doing something on him right now though
isn't something happening right now some
new Bruce Lee thing that I read that or
my just hoping there's a movie coming
out about a dude who's a famous actor in
the late 60s and early 70s and
the movie he's he's a stuntman yeah he's
a famous rich stuntman dude and in the
movie there's a Bruce Lee part where
he's in a Bruce Lee movie and also in a
Quentin Tarantino movie called Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood oh that's nice but
it's not is it CGI Bruce Lee no there's
an actor it's a nice they should have
went with the CGI Bruce oh yeah I could
make a new Bruce Lee movie all CGI they
can do that [ __ ] magic no do you
loominatee doesn't want you to know how
good they aren't that yet okay so if the
Illuminati created Bruce Lee what would
be the reason well they would if they
did it they would let you know hey
[ __ ] we already can make movies out
of anybody anytime we want we could have
someone talk like Bruce Lee look at that
wait a minute a guy looks very good
what's that CGI um right there I mean
it's close enough is that the new Bruce
Lee this is just a post from the trailer
so there's that I do the only piece we
can get oh you know what that CGI no
okay no no it's not CG no no not for
sure it's CGI that first clip first clip
down right there CG oh it's glasses he's
wearing its face [ __ ] it looks like a
CGI video game oh they did something to
his jaw it looks like a CGI face no he
has an eye looks real but that's cuz
you've seen him in a different angle
watch back it up to where he's up at the
side what if they're doing like that
bacony to me hold on hold on me that
looks everything
oh stop is exhausting um it could have
no if they wanted to watch it didn't
fast and furious with Paul Walker right
they recreated his face well they need
to do a Bruce Lee movie they can't have
it [ __ ] up at all it has to be super
smooth it has to be it has to be really
Bruce Lee asked totally and you know
what you could do it like that movie man
this was like 20 years ago the Final
Fantasy movie where they did animation
but they try to make it look real yeah
old people they got that [ __ ] down they
got old people down harder and make a
young girl look real so that cutout is
still a cartoon effect but older people
[ __ ] look like real people yeah they can
do it with textured skins right yeah do
with drag
and that was 20 years ago they could do
movies that are full CGI that's really
hard to tell
well it's also because your brain
doesn't have like a reference point for
dragons they can make a dragon look real
well it's like a juicy Game of Thrones
so they have the wolves yeah the wolves
are always just like the hare moved five
years away from here it moves to slow-mo
super slow-mo that is them that popped
up here on this video yeah Michael Moe
that's the dude so when you see him with
the glasses and see him from the side he
should uh that's interesting I I don't
know if they could do the CGI yet for a
whole movie and make him with Bruce
Lee's face I could do it perfect wow
that's crazy so they could have done
that but then they get if everybody else
in the movie isn't like Steve McQueen
and all the other famous folks in the
movie like you're they using different
people for them or that that would be
[ __ ] up imagine if in the future all
they ever make is like Charles Bronson
movies Steve McQueen movies Bruce Lee
movies and they do it with regular
actors and the regular actors get paid
like scale these are giant ants and they
do fake and do fake getting on them and
they have new Bruce Lee movies and they
have some dude I'd be a horse he'll rope
they added Princess Leia back oh she's
not even alive anymore I didn't see the
new one yeah so there you go maybe I did
is that the ones with them though
they're doing it now she's in the moat
more recent one that just came out and
the one before that too I guess I think
I saw the most was the most recent
there's a lot of yeah I think I'm I
think I'm one behind I think I missed I
haven't seen the New Avengers I've
managed to avoid all spoil about when
they start doing like like they'll take
Angelina leaves face and everyone's all
leave and put it on like you know
Beyonce's body or something remember
that song see how big old titties like
Angelina Jolie no that's wrong yeah
doing that sounds a great song that was
a big hit we got about that yeah
Angelina Jolie got some big ass
that was a song that was the Hult it was
like different people that had some
big-ass titties that was the name of the
song